people are making podcasts and thinking
in 90 days they're somehow going to blow
up in the beginning 150 episodes is just
me talking about how to run a gym better
i got a dm the other day somebody who's
like yeah it's easy for you to build
this brand because you already have this
big audience i was like dude just start
he was discouraged by the fact that he
had no following he had no audience etc
99 of people who are watching this do
more cool [ __ ] and then you'll have cool
[ __ ] to talk about rather than
regurgitating other people's stuff but
for everyone who sees the overnight
success right what i want you to do is
go to my podcast and look at the time
stamp of my first episode this 2017.
five and a half six years ago it just
now hit the top ten and in that six year
period
i did not miss every week one to three
podcasts
for six years and so people are making
podcasts and thinking in 90 days they're
somehow going to blow up when the
reality is that you're finding your
voice for the first year you're figuring
out what way you communicate you're
learning how to teach how to entertain
how to present you're learning how to
speak and you're also learning about the
stuff that you're learning meantime
right like in that period of time i
might not have had as much stuff that
was as cool in the beginning that
applied to as many people because the
first 150 episodes is just me talking
about how to run a gym better right
around 150 i started talking about
marketing in general because that's what
i was into at the time and then i
started talking about sales and i
started talking about business in
general and m and things that as they've
evolved over time and so the subject
matter as well as my skill in delivering
it both improved over that period of
time and now the podcast is top 10 on
entrepreneurship and very high ranked in
business next to names that i i looked
up to my whole career i'm like holy cow
i'm like we're wait we just
went about this guy that i've been
looking up to my whole life it doesn't
take 90 days
it takes years if you think in days the
time's gonna pass no matter what but if
you can think in decades when you make
your goals when that decade does pass
it'll show that you were thinking that
way
right not the outcome the goal make the
action the goal if the action is
did i make the post did i make the reach
outs every day then you're a success you
check both boxes i want to tell you a
quick story so there was a guy who
started at the first gym with me same
day
all right and we've been friends since
then and i started my gym and then he
started his gym and he started changing
gym so we went in parallel all right and
he ended up selling those gyms and he
wanted to go online he was like dude i
need to build like a brand i was like
dude you just need to start posting you
know short form stuff making stuff
that's valuable
he posted every day
for
six months
and then one video took off and then the
next video took off and the next video
took off and then all of a sudden now
he's making a hundred thousand dollars a
month from the content that he was
making he'd already been doing business
for nine years and then all of a sudden
it took off and he and he messaged me he
was like i'm super grateful that that
you told me to do that and so he did the
post and he did the reach outs and what
ended up happening is that earlier on he
would he would have videos that would
start taking off he would start doing
reach and start making sales and then
he'd make some money and then he would
slow down and then all of a sudden you
get in scarcity mode once he was like oh
shoot there's no money coming in there's
no money coming in
and then you start making content start
doing reshots again and you make money
again and he was like dude how do i
break the cycle and what we did was we
shifted what he was focusing on because
he was focusing on the sales he was
making he's focusing all the money he
was making rather than focusing on the
process you are not successful in my
eyes
because whenever you see some outcome
you stop the activities which means you
don't have the trait of consistency
that's like the reason you aren't where
you want to be is because you can't do
things repeatedly and so most people
can't do one thing over and over again
you need to be able to do the doing
without seeing the result of your doing
and you have to keep doing it and if you
can keep doing things independent and
this is both ways if it goes really well
you keep doing the thing that got you
there and if it's not going well comma
yet
you keep doing the thing so that you get
good enough that one day it will and
that's the shift that most people don't
make and i think that's why most people
just stay poor and the reality is that
if you can commit to the actions and the
behaviors and the traits that you will
grow through doing then at the end of
this process a decade later you will be
the type of person who can do something
for a long period of time and wait and i
promise you that if you have that trait
money will never be a constraint in your
life and this is from atomic habits
every winner and every loser have the
same goals
so when you measure yourself by having
this external thing and people like set
goals
everyone wants to be rich
everyone wants to have a six-pack your
goals don't make you unique
it's the activities that you do that
make you unique the goal of the winner
is to commit to the activities the goal
of the loser is to commit to the goal 52
percent of 18 year olds high school
seniors think they're going to be
millionaires by 25. the world is going
to be shook
many of you will fail and that's because
most of you have the same goal 52
percent you think you're gonna be a
millionaire right it's just math but
only a small percentage will because
if you want to be a millionaire you're
not going to focus on making a million
dollars you're going to focus on the
stuff that makes a million dollars and
so when you can divorce
the activities from the outcome
then you can focus on the doing which
whether your income does this over that
period of time your self-esteem remains
the same because you're committing to
what you can control
if you can make that shift
it will change your life so i started
making podcasts six years ago i
committed to that process when i signed
on with a youtube vendor a few years ago
on the first call i said
i'd like to have this channel be
something in five to ten years i was
like we'll look at it then and see if it
was worth continuing to do i was like
but i'm in for a decade and he stopped
me afterwards he was like i've literally
never had a client say that to me
ever he's like they're all like how can
i get leads in the first 90 days from
youtube and like blah blah blah i was
like if we're making progress
i'm good
will commit to that i think that if you
can think that way you will get what you
want and then people will ask you a
decade from now man how did you have
this overnight success and blah blah
blah blah and aren't you like don't the
followers and the fans like how does it
not get to your head and you're like
because it was never the goal and so i
feel just as good at year one as i do at
year eight because the activities that i
committed to remain the same if you can
think that way and you can shift your
perspective it will it'll decrease your
emotional ups and downs and i think we
all need ways to decrease our emotional
ups and downs in the game of business
because like we need to have second
lives the third lives and fourth lives
and the way to do that is to not put
your life
your game playing life in something that
you can't control but putting all your
game playing life in the things you can
right now we just crossed our 400th
episode
400 episodes
like if i did one a week that's 52
four eight one a week for a year that
would be eight years of doing that if i
had 400 episodes i'm at like year six if
you make 400 long-form pieces of content
i guarantee you that your following
would be bigger than it is today well
how long is that going to take
as long as it takes because the goal was
never the outcome the goal was to do
anything
you